>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS LIVE IN
PARIS.
OLD ACCUSATIONS IN A NEW FORM TO
LABOR "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTING ON WHAT IT SAYS WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DIRECT
INVOLVEMENT ON THE HUSH MONEY
PAYOFFS WOMEN ALLEGING SEXUAL
INVOLVEMENT, WHICH COULD BE
ILLEGAL.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THE PRESIDENT VIOLATED CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAWS, THAT ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
A VERY INTERESTING STORY, A BIT
OF A BLOCKBUSTER COMING OUT THIS
EVENING.
LET ME SHARE JUST A BIT WHAT
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" IS
SAYING THIS EVENING AND THAT
REPORT.
IT'S A LENGTHY REPORT.
IT SAYS, AMONGST OTHER THINGS,
IT'S REFUTING THE PRESIDENT, IS
LEGAL TEAM, ADVISORS, ALL DENIED
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAD ANY
INVOLVEMENT IN HUSH MONEY
PAYOFFS OF FORMER ADULT FILM
PERFORMER STORMY DANIELS AND
ANOTHER WOMAN DURING THE 26 TEAM
CAMPAIGN.
THROUGH ITS INVESTIGATION, THIS
NOW RAISES THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THE PRESIDENT VIOLATED FINANCE
LAWS BECAUSE IT CLAIMS MR. TRUMP
WAS INVOLVED IN OR BRIEFED ON
EVERY STEP OF THE HUSH MONEY
ARRANGEMENTS AND THE AGREEMENTS
THERE, ALLEGING HE ENGAGED IN OR
DIRECTED THE DEALS BY TELEPHONE
AND/OR IN MEETINGS WITH HIS
SELF-DESCRIBED FIXER MICHAEL
COHEN.
THIS COMES BY WAY OF EVIDENCE
GATHERED BY THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
MIAMI USING RECORDINGS MADE BY
MR. COHEN.
THEY ACTUALLY EXTRACTED A GUILTY
PLEA FROM MR. COHEN, THE
PRESIDENT'S FORMER FIXER BACK IN
AUGUST.
THEY CONVICTED HIM OF CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAW VIOLATIONS,
CONVERSATIONS OR MEETINGS WITH
ONE OR MORE MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN TEAM.
ONE PERSON ACCORDING TO THE
REPORT, OR AT LEAST IT WAS
SUGGESTED, THAT PERSON WAS THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
ASIDE FROM THE PRESIDENT'S
DENIALS, WE KNOW THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS OFFERED A SERIES OF THE
NAILS ABOUT HIS INVOLVEMENT IN
THE CIRCUMSTANCE.
YOU REMEMBER EARLY IN THE YEAR,
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SARAH SANDERS SAID NONE OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE TRUE.
BACK IN MAY, WE HEARD RUDY
GIULIANI DESCRIBE THE PAYMENTS
TO DANIELS, WELL, THE PRESIDENT
PAID HIM BACK.
NO CRIME OF ANY KIND.
MICHAEL, THAT IS COHEN, HAD
DISCRETION TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS.
WE HEARD JAY SEKULOW WOODFIELD
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE CIRCUMSTANCE
BUT WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM HIM